I am thrilled to have here on this show
in the flesh to my right the man who is
seventh in NFL history in all-purpose
yards seventh in most receiving yards in
NFL history 12th in most receptions in
NFL history and nobody has put on a
Carolina Panthers uniform to rack up
more total touchdowns catches or
receiving yards he is none other than
Steve Smith good to see you sir you know
I am better for you being here there's
no question about that and everybody at
the NFL Network could not be more fired
up that you chose us yeah I'm sure you
had your options I'm enjoying it I'm
learning a lot what are you learning how
to drink water from a fire hazard or
straw instead of learning no way because
I was about to think to myself we don't
we don't we don't provide straws or fire
hydrants and so it's a lot you know I've
put on myself to learn a lot you know
work the draft did that the first round
I already learned a lot of things did to
come by so I'm learning football from a
front office perspective and I've really
been enjoying it did you do to combine
as a player did you go through the
combine is yes I went through the combo
I went through it as a different ways
it's totally different now yeah I know
so you were at the old one Scouting
Combine I was that was there yes and
there were no TV cameras the NFL Network
and all was two years from from existing
a matter of fact the first Super Bowl we
have recovered was your Hannibal it
wasn't you anywhere we did this where we
just went last year yes I know where New
England showed up again I know that kind
of stung when you just said it I didn't
mean it I didn't I was like oh yeah yeah
they showed up the same quarterback same
guy yep same same division and see Sal
that's right
NFC South versus versus a am suing
resiliency sounds and so I just want to
get back to so you this is your hometown
here in Los Angeles yes you were and you
went to Santa Monica Community Community
College yes on with the University High
School hmm
with the para ver / Emerson oh no and so
you went to Santa Monica Community
College because why did you go do that I
decided my junior
here today I wanted to start paying
attention in school okay um and it was
my opportunity
we used to had West LA Southwest wasn't
very good um he had a West LA in Santa
Monica and so I chose Santa Monica it
was a great culture SSO robert taylor
who gave me an opportunity and it worked
out and Chad Johnson was your teammate
there correct yes Chad we were on the
team together yes why would you not use
the word teammate right see I pick up
what you say yes and I know I want you
to put down only what you mean yeah when
you open your mouth Community College
generally if you're playing sports is a
two-year commitment mm-hmm I was there
two years and Joe as he was eventually
to be known went to Oregon State for one
for one you went to Utah but how did you
go to Utah how did they were recruiting
another guy who's like my older brother
who passed away as well Demetrius Posey
I played in the slot so I was really
following him they saw Chad and
Demetrius and then they'd say hey we
like Steve um and so they'd offer me and
I went up there really following him
mm-hmm
um and the coach the wide receivers
coaches Fred grades he coached a guy
named Brian Cox I think it was at New
Mexico State and Brian Cox was the
sports director at Bennett's Park where
I grew up uh so that's how you all
connect together no basically so what I
saw Brian what I saw what he was as a
father and a husband and what he made
and how he worked I say you know he's
helped him out and he's done well for
itself so if anything I get a great
education not be able to provide and you
know have a good job and a lot of other
people that came in you know the one
thing going through the process of my
kids you know the college recruiting
system is different you know these guys
come in sometimes they don't look the
same color as you and they come in and
to some of the environments and the
first thing comes out at my office trust
me
and I had a guy who was african-american
who grew up in Compton who understood
the ladle and he also knew and coached
people that I respect the new the ladle
and so the similarities I can relate and
I thought they were very similar and I
had the opportunity and the chance so I
what the guy that I relate it to versus
some of the other guys who were coming
in that you know the first thing when
you meet a stranger and first thing they
say is trust me no I'm not going to
trust you mmm-hmm and this guy he didn't
do that as well Steve Smith here on the
Rich Eisen show so you go to Utah and
then you wound up what was it like
somebody from Los Angeles is different
showing up in Utah
especially uh-oh one it was different
but I I wanted to go wherever was going
to give me opportunity to go for free
because I could we couldn't afford to go
anywhere u.s. he didn't want me San
Diego State didn't want me so I said hey
you know there's my opportunity it was a
San Jose State Utah and Sam Houston
State and the guy who recruited me Sam
Houston could trust me guy he actually
they said so I got into Utah but I
couldn't get in Sam Houston so okay
so I don't have a grace with Sam Houston
by the grace for Utah where does the
chip on your shoulder come from some
people say it's a chip I just kind of
look at aware that the opportunities
that I had or the lack of opportunities
you know and I somewhat my didn't for
various reasons some of them were
self-inflicted wounds and some of it was
a you know some of the discrimination of
height that's always where hike
discriminators yes some um you know you
into this even to this day you know some
people I had a guy we were me on my cell
in South Bay gallery and GEICO's Steve
like man I respect you even more just
seeing you how short you are you know I
was like thanks hello so you think it
let's just say if you were a Julio Jones
moose and Mohammed who was a teammate of
yours and if you had that height and
weight you'd be a different person
different player you think
um personality-wise I think as soon as
you say yeah personality because you
only have all attributes you work with
less I think I think sometimes because
of these are advantages and I'll do it
tomorrow and we all know what how many
times we said we'll do it tomorrow you
say that sometimes oh there's a few
times as I got older it was one time I
didn't want to work out I called my
workout guy who's been my working guy
for like he was like eight nine years
and I went online looking my bank
account so more when I used to build
Morgan standing I was like I'm straight
I had to work out today when was that
uh it's probably my 10th 11th year I was
like oh good what did you what did you
work out guys say to you on that day
right I don't know I told him I wasn't
working actually I texted hey I'm not
working out I'll see them all and he
took that as a yes I mean every time
different time zone I'll work out right
like I'll be like man I'm done when did
you know that you were done Steve what
did you know the was that so when I got
released I was working out rehabbing my
knee and going into that year I was like
man I kind of feel it this is getting
time and that year that I said I was
that whole offseason when I trained on
my guy I was literally working out I was
going this hurt and then last year I
worked out and I and when I was working
out last year I knew I was like you know
what come on
I'm straight mm-hmm and then that was
the end of that yep have you read on it
at any point no not at once
will you will you will you in September
when you're sitting there on set of NFL
gameday first probably where you're cold
time being but way before the Sun comes
up yeah you think it's been two times I
saw when I was in Baltimore with
ladarius would have had a softball game
and I was up there doing some stuff for
the network back to back to camp and
walk around the house cool and then when
I had to say goodbye to guys
I hop on the plane to go back to
Charlotte
got a little choked up because it was a
real goodbye wasn't like hey see you
guys in it was like so I got a little
choked up and then on when we had our
summit and they've shown the highlights
sorry
you started out kind of a little that so
so when we're sitting there in the NFL
when I saw the opening okay and they
started I was like man I'm like wow it
just hit me
they showed highlights of all the other
guy I was sitting on and it'll happen
also but it was a videos to highlight a
2016 season oh and you were you were I
wanted to on there but it was just a
fact of the season I was like man I
experienced that and I will never the
grieving pot prop the grieving process
has been different in a good way but
I've grieved a little bit because it is
um next to my wife it is my only love
you know as far as like my first true
love that fell in love with this ball
and I no longer will be able to
participate anymore
and I was like it kind of hit me I was
like ah so for the last six seven months
the first three was tough now the last
three man I am enjoying okay work out my
working I work out with my wife um just
stay in shape
got a got a friendly way to a hike okay
look yeah so I'm working out but keep
that what's your friendly his wager is
that he thinks I'm going to get stung by
multiple bees and I blow up and get that
so long okay so it's that it's that you
know how I guess the freshman 15 in
college correct be the freshman fresh
off retirement it's like it you're done
you don't need to be ready for Sunday's
anymore you are just going to just
fatten up yes and he's bet you that you
will do that yes by Christmas
Wow so what how much are you right now
what are you I've lost five about 10
pounds of muscle so I was a when I first
started doing it I was like 205 because
I really took the first 30 days off okay
I kind of went as a as the young guy say
Yolo
oh how these all kind of stuff
and so I said made and so uh my little
bit so I got out of the shower to myself
and I was like mmm mmm then my wife
walked past you guys out and I was like
oh yeah like mommy your mama night
together okay
and so long so I dropped down by one 95
or 96 or so me and my son worked out
yesterday got on the treadmill I'm gonna
be I'm gonna take you in this instead of
like trust me oh yeah I don't he won't
get my money I told my wanting in
quarters too
I want all the [ __ ] Steve Smith is here
for all three hours of this show we're
just getting started in 60 seconds I
want to ask you our poll question about
who the best player in the National
Football League is and then hit you on
some topics because you're part of the
paparazzi now yes okay
you're not playing any badge or anything
I get a free camera uh you get not know
what you do is you get a symposium and a
video and lunch and that's it and the
salary you got it yeah okay Steve Smith
in 60 seconds more with him in a moment
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah the TV's we come back on the TV
sites your understand demonic appear
that's that's old that's that's your old
stomping grounds in a way seems to work
is that I worked at Ferris wheel what do
you mean I worked at the first one so
when people come here to Los Angeles and
to see that famous Ferris wheel I worked
it we have to balance it out what do you
mean I was an employee I got paid from
no no I mean what do you mean I balance
it out like so if somebody comes up and
you still get heavier you gotta wait and
you got to balance it out that thing
hold it sir your job was to tell people
were we bigger in the community in a way
oh man
how did you how did you break the news
that we were just how many okay how many
we're going to take those and you had to
bounce it out because you when you're
going on there you have to let them off
and let them on yeah and have it the
right balance because they'll sway and
all that stuff are you telling me the
next time I show up to a ferris wheel
and I'm told to hang on and wait it's
it's an indication I need to drop some
others maybe the person who is ahead of
you
Oh ordinates behind you leave it on the
fat guy we just got on I didn't say that
hey our poll question is brought to you
by the Honda fourth-of-july sales event
it's your chance to find deals on the
Accord and civic with the available
suite of Honda sensing technologies
designed to help you avoid the things
you miss hurry in before it's too late
the new Honda Odyssey that I'm driving
around caught your eye when I girls on
the NFL Network lon correct yes it's
nice so you've got four kids right uh
well Peyton is 19 okay
he's know what he does not be myself as
a kid he's now a grown know young man
okay young man at what did you become a
grown man um waned you off my books okay
and when do you become a grown-ass man
when just want to become a grown-ass man
when you live in your old house okay or
apartment whatever or when you need when
you have to ring the doorbell to get
into our home ding don't visitor hey hey
PD
welcome to grown-ass man yes who did you
bring with [ __ ] how old is your how old
are your kids
so Payton is 19 years my daughter's 15/3
should be 16 September I lay or what are
you gonna be like when somebody comes to
court your daughter I'll be very
entertaining um and there is no man good
enough for my daughter I think you know
she waits til she's 45 I'm clearly that
okay yeah what is there was there a
problem in the past or anything like
that with your daughter and all she's a
she's only a something okay
I said I've got only eight six and three
I can't you know what I need to go visit
1915 12 and soon-to-be three little
deuce little deuce yes
ask the pull question of Steve Smith
Chris Brock I don't know how I can even
follow up forth yeah top 100 revealed
last night Steve the top six we got here
who's the best player heading into this
year's NFL season Tom Brady Von Miller
Julio Jones Antonio Brown Coyle Mac
Aaron Rodgers have to choose one of the
top six that there's revealed and voted
on by their peers on last night's top
100 list so if I don't work I'm an
employee in a film Network um I've never
voted on the NFL Network poll I did see
one guy was voting for another pole in
front network and they were kickers when
I was in Baltimore so are you saying
that this is not I'm not saying that the
list is not valid I'm just questioning
who are all of the participant voters of
the top 100 because I was not on that
list at any point in my I got a 14 years
yeah 16 year I've never been up you
would have been I've been asked about a
guy but I've never been asked to cast my
vote okay now you are yeah I am now
actually giving you that operating you a
pool of six players all right so Steve
Smith you have now been officially asked
by a fellow member of the NFL Network
who who's my top yes the guy who wanted
Tom Brady okay I mean yes I figure I owe
you I think that's very simple but I
mean
we really live in the Rings the thing
I'm not I mean I'm not looking at the
ring is the thing I'm just looking at
what he has orchestrated over a
consistent period of time and also age
discriminating looking at his age his
body of work what he's doing but this is
not a lifetime achievement of what we're
talking about going into this fall but
he's still playing in this Lifetime
Achievement Award right it's not like
he's you know he's retired or he's he's
two-year three years removed he's
balling right now two game suspension
whether you like it or not just the
things he's doing how he makes guys
better you take I love Wes Walker
respect the heck out of him he's only
played with two quarterbacks why is that
that's that he has been relevant Tom
Brady and Peyton Manning everybody else
he has not been well soccer and so you
look at what he's done you look at a guy
like um Eric Decker I look at Eric
Decker he was okay with the Jets he was
phenomenal in Denver and what the Jays
got was not what he was in Denver and
you see what's happening why who that he
played with he's playing with he's
playing with Peyton Manning so okay I'm
hearing all this would you then say you
balled out regardless of who your
quarterback was would you never why we
should measure I've never played with a
living goat as a quarterback I play with
some guys I respect and I think a very
good but I've never played with a Peyton
Manning I've never played with a you
know Warren Moon a Boomer Esiason I mean
there's a number Joe Montana Steve Young
there's a number of guys I love football
our study football I've never played
with some of those guys that when they
walk in a room you go mmm you know I've
never played with those guys but I have
played with some guys I respect and I
think a very good are great but not some
of the greatest players I've never
experienced only through via bubbles
Steve
here on the Rich Eisen show so is Flacco
a leak or an elite quarterback you get
later I think there would be some I
would think there would be some GM's and
some head coaches out on Figueroa Martin
Luther King Boulevard right there two
snooty Fox that would be pimping
themselves out to get a quarterback like
him compared to some of the other
quarterbacks there on display and
rosters right now so because since he
balled out yeah in that Super Bowl
season correct he has not come close to
that level of play and he's had he's had
you not as if he didn't have but also
things have changed the defensive faces
have changed some receivers have changed
his inconsistency with having a steady
offensive coordinator over the same
amount of years all those things play a
great example of a guy who I think got a
bum rap two guys Jason Campbell and Alex
Smith they scan will he's with the
Washington Redskins played with numerous
different offensive coordinators and
head coaches even to the point of when
he was in Auburn never had consistency
if you don't have consistency in your
work force it is very hard to be
effective in your job then also Alex
Smith the inconsistency of head coaches
oftens coordinators when he was with the
49ers and you see now he's not a Super
Bowl winning MVP quarterback but he's
doing decent numbers to where they're
going into playoff so he's consistent
right there in Kansas City all right
Steve Smith is here on the Rich Eisen
she'll put them down for Tom Brady where
does the poll stand just at the end of
the first three segments of our big
Tuesday show Tom Brady wins the way so
far 39% 23% for Aaron Rodgers 11% calmac
10% Otoniel Brown 10% Julio Jones 7%
Vaughn no no buffer no love for fun Wow
when we come back though I do want to
ask you you did play with Cam when he
came out and he did smash Peyton
Manning's rookie records and I would do
want to ask you about cams viability
moving forward as a star quarterback in
this league if I may sir
beer Steve Smith is sitting right here
on the set and then also still to come
in the Chris command center news up
segment that's coming up at the top of
our number two did you catch the
Uwe last night put the shirtless
wrestler yeah named levar ball did you
catch that yes also a Saul's boobs that
Steve Smith here on the Rich Eisen show
don't you dare move we'll talk about
that as well in the Chris command sent
your news update that's coming up at the
top of our to that has none other than
Sean McVeigh joining in studio with
Steve Smith
Rams head coach Shawn McVeigh soon to
join us here in studio the us being
Steve Smith Chris Brockman and I and it
is now time for a numbers game brought
to you by our friends at motor medic go
for it take that back a bit today number
guys it's a numbers game a lot of
numbers guy but that doesn't seem to add
up it is no secret that a clean engine
is a healthy engine and when used before
every oil change motor medic motor flush
eliminates contaminants that build up
over time giving your car more power
better performance in a longer engine
life which we're all looking for so pick
up motor medic motor flush today at your
favorite automotive retailer and get
more out of every oil change what is
today's number guy over there yeah cool
moment last night at the NBA awards
leads to today's number one hundred and
forty six thousand four hundred and
fifty total number of career points
including playoff performances from the
players that took the stage last night
Kareem abdul-jabbar Shaquille O'Neal
Alonzo Mourning dikembe mutombo
and David Robinson all presented Bill
Russell with a lifetime achievement
achievement award and before starting
his acceptance speech 82 year old Bill
Russell pointed to all five of the big
men and sold a show with the line of the
night we kick your ass
what a line not a pill Russell I think
it pretty good not to argue you ever met
Bill Russell you ever may unfortunately
no not yet I got a list of people on me
like who oh what's wrong oh I'm a Jordan
have you met Jim Brown no I have not
I'm not imagine but that is always
intense really oh yes I don't think I
want me to know another cue what
what about intense meeting intense I
mean you're I'm trying to lay on really
trying to just chill okay this isn't
going great for him I met Ricky Watters
okay yeah well so why you're chill let's
bring up Cam Newton okay um what was he
like when he came into the league um
I think like every rookie you know
especially a rookie quarterback
believing in himself and taking out he's
gonna take it uh he's gonna be the guy
um you know and I'm sure that's what you
want you want a guy going Romero hope I
could get it together right you know you
don't want that um I mean every every
quarterback that's coming out now that's
that's drafted high I mean they're
they're treated like superstars and
rightfully so because our game has our
game and a college game has changed
tremendously
why did you retire a Riven well I
retired with the team I was with um
because also I just wanted to get out of
the way so my family and stuff that was
done and also to I was subject to still
being under the NFL policy of anything
happened I also have had three
spontaneous PD's testing and I just
didn't want to deal with it and so I I
said they said to only only way for me
not to have to deal with all this stuff
that I had to submit some kind of
paperwork so I submitted some paperwork
and I'd literally for probably month and
a half had to call the guys and like
look I'm not coming back they said well
if you want to come back um you got to
take these drug tests and not drug tests
like oh I'm doing drugs but mainly
saying that to continue to play the show
teams that you're
well I was like oh I'm not interested so
I submitted my paperwork and said look
I'm done you know I have no desire to
play um on record right now I have three
drug test office I failed to appear for
and so I actually if I try to reinstate
and play oh I'll be suspended I've only
got a minute for you left and I'm sure
you could talk a day on the subject so
that said what about retiring as a
panther but now that what now that you
removed from that you're not coming back
folks in Carolina would love to see you
in the Panthers somehow get that
together what do you think about that
IRS says I live in Charlotte I'm a
resident of Charlotte I have some
business have Foundation in Charlotte I
continue to live and contribute to that
community but as of today June 27th at
this time um I'm retired Steve Smith I
worked in for network and it's really
not on my radar as of today when if it
comes about um in due process due time
I'll think about but right now right now
I am what I say yellow chilla
right here on the Rich Eisen show for
the next two hours when we come back
Sean McVeigh the new head coach of the
young Los Angeles Rams yeah
he's going to make us he's going to make
us feel old just by showing up here no I
have to watch soon he'll lose his hair
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on radio stations across the
country and audience if you like some of
that get some more of that on the Rich
Eisen show lap follow all the
information you see right here on the
Rich Eisen show